restrictions on genetically modified
organisms are high on the agenda as EU
environment ministers meet in Luxembourg
the council is expected to reach a
political agreement on rules that will
allow member states to restrict or
prohibit the cultivation of some GMOs on
their territories even if they're
authorized at EU level the aims to
provide a legal basis to limit GMO
cultivation on grounds other than health
or environmental considerations
conditions which are already taken into
account in the current rules while
they're widely grown in the Americas and
Asia genetically modified crops are
generally unpopular in Europe
environmentalists have raised concerns
about the impact on biodiversity
Europe's clear air program is also up
for discussion this time in public
debate the program sets limits on
harmful emissions from industry traffic
energy plants and agriculture The
ministers will express their views on a
proposal for new rules on medium-sized
combustion plants which are used for
residential heating and cooling and
providing heat or steam for industry
they'll also look at national air
pollutant emission ceilings